this is a weird question but I was going
to ask it has your intuition ever failed
you because I get the sense that you
trust your intuition and you really go
off that when it comes with certain
things that's a really really difficult
question to answer because I you know as
all the storytellers and all the artists
out there know especially in LA there's
this really weird pushing pool between
your own intuition and then also this
other thing of like feedback you know
people will tell you that won't sell but
that doesn't translate or these are the
rules or you don't do that I think my
initial kind of primal intuition is
always being a little bit more
rebellious
I don't like Authority I don't like
being told you can do this I've always
been interested in some things that are
like left-of-center per se so I think
you know my intuition you know has been
challenged so many times because people
will come and say well that doesn't
really work you know or that is kind of
not how you do it
so it's been kind of an interesting
journey or a struggle because I do think
that somewhere along the way because
filmmaking is a collaborative process
and you have to like open yourself up to
suggestions and different perspectives
but at the same time I do think that
storytellers and artists and filmmakers
or whoever actors writers you have to
open up the windows a little bit for for
perspective and feedback but you also
have to be be really mindful of what
your internal kind of voices and and so
to answer your question sometimes I feel
like I'm really good with my instincts
and sometimes I'm I'm really proud of it
and sometimes I don't know because I
haven't been able to test a lot of
things in the marketplace you know I
mean you and I off-camera we talked a
little bit about David Lynch
and how you know I mean I'm a big fan of
his work and this is a guy whose work is
so specific and I'm such a fan of his
work you know but he's been proven in
the marketplace and so people have an
understanding that that's his signature
you know so people will leave him alone
you can do whatever you want because
there's a fan base there you know but I
think when you're you know just sort of
emerging in the marketplace and you're
trying to figure out what your voice is
what kind of stories are interesting to
you and you don't have all the money and
all the access to people who can help
you make that vision come to life then
you start to make little compromises
along the way you know and then
somewhere along the way the magic of
collaborating happens where your movie
can become better than you expected but
also somewhere along the way you might
start to like lose a sense of your own
voice because you don't know whether you
got a chance to really experiment with
that does that make sense you know I
mean it's kind of a long answer to your
question no I think I guess to answer
your question I think it's an ongoing
ongoing thing that happens with
storytellers that's kind of figured out
I don't really know what it is yet you
know is that right so you know fighting
finding a good collaborator is really
important what's the balance the scales
you know that was yeah exactly and it
seems like you have a lot of that
balance yeah I don't know I'm a Libra
and apparently libras are never balanced
they're always seeking balance okay so
I'm always in flux that's what that's
good though that you you it's better
than I think thinking like I'm always
right that you're put you you you trust
your gut and then that works because
maybe then you're able to be free with
certain things and creatively and
explore different ideas but then may be
humble enough for lack of a better word
of being like okay I may not always be
right and I'm open to hearing somebody
else's process yeah I mean I think I
think a good
well some for me generally speaking is
the best idea wins you know but but but
to be very honest that is a lot easier
said than done you know when you start
to involve you know paste when you start
to involve gut instincts you know these
are things that are very subjective
these are things that are really
difficult to kind of value you know when
when you're talking about taste so I
think I think I think all of that stuff
is just part of the part of the
experience of making the film you know
same thing for actors you know they get
a few different takes and then they sort
of surrender that to the filmmakers you
know and the writers sort of surrender
that to the director and producers you
know so at the end of the day is just a
collaborative process and everybody is
sort of just you know throwing it out
there to see what lands I like that the
best answer would what it was it the
best idea wins
yeah the best idea wins you know and and
so but you know it's tough yeah I mean
I'm just thinking about I've been
watching a lot of documentaries on Apple
and Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak if it
had been to Steve Jobs it probably
wouldn't have worked - Wozniak that
wouldn't have worked yes but because the
combination was right right it works and
I'm just thinking like you know you said
that somehow you just know it's going to
work whereas maybe you meet somebody who
you're great friends with but in terms
of collaborating right on a film that's
going to have some rough times right
have some great times not every night is
going to be screening yes absolutely you
know that that's the one night that
probably everything's going to go great
but yeah but you just have to have that
right combination yeah I think I think
with this project like many other
projects there's got to be kind of a
heart to it you know and I think in the
beginning that heart really belonged to
Melissa you know she was really kind of
compelled to tell a story of some kind
that resembled what we ended up putting
on screen
you know and and there was something
that kind of pulled her to that you know
and so the process was really us trying
to like pull the pieces apart and trying
to reattach them together and see what's
interesting so we're really really proud
of the film the final product so
you